foreign
[Music]
Spencer here for Jihad watch a program
of the David Horowitz Freedom Center and
for the center for security policy Sean
Andrew Duncan is a 21 year old convert
to Islam in Virginia who is under
investigation for ties to the Islamic
State that is Isis in the course of the
investigation agents found that Duncan
was in possession of child pornography
and was seeking a second wife while
still being married to his first a 36
year old physician named zakiya sadek
whom he met at Islamic Gatherings Duncan
embodies a phenomenon that authorities
so far have determinedly ignored the
lethal convert to Islam
after all where did Sean Andrew Duncan
get the idea to do all these things
could these ideas have had anything to
do with his new peaceful religion could
it be from Islam that he got the idea
that murdering non-muslims was a
righteous act which is in the Quran at
chapter 2 verse 191 chapter 4 verse 89
and chapter 9 verse 5 and that
prepubescent children could be objects
of erotic interest remember Muhammad the
Supreme model of conduct for Muslims
consummated his marriage with the
nine-year-old Aisha when he was 54 and
that polygamy was moral and worth
pursuing as the Quran says at chapter 4
verse 3. or would such thinking be
islamophobic
nor is Sean Andrew Duncan by any means
the only convert to Islam to attract law
enforcement attention in San Diego
recently another convert to Islam
Marcelo Deshawn McCain was sentenced to
10 years in prison for possessing an
illegal Firearms cache and lying to
investigators he had planned to join the
Islamic State McCain's brother Douglas
was killed while waging Jihad in Syria
in 2014.
then there was ever at Aaron Jameson AKA
Abdullah Abu everit IBN Gordon al-amriki
according to the Associated Press this
convert to Islam planned to use pipe
bombs at San Francisco's popular Pier 39
on Christmas day to force people to flee
into an arena where he could shoot them
Alam Riki a former Marine declared I was
a soldier in the kufar that is
unbeliever Army before I reverted that
is converted to Islam I have been
trained in combat and things of war
inshallah that is Allah willing anything
of that nature as well as funding
anything for Allah he said that he
wanted to replicate recent Jihad mass
murder attacks in New York City and San
Bernardino California
when they searched his home shortly at
before Christmas FBI agents found a
statement reading I Abdullah Abu Everett
IBN Gordon have committed these acts
upon the kufar that is the unbelievers
in the name of Dar al-islam that is the
house of Islam Allahu Akbar
you all have brought this upon
yourselves there is no innocent kuffar
each and every kufar in this
nationalistic Godless Society has a hand
in this you've allowed Donald J Trump to
give away our Goods that is Jerusalem to
the Jews both you and he are wrong it
belongs to the Muslim that is the
Muslims we have penetrated and
infiltrated your disgusting country
these acts will continue until the Lions
of Islam overtake you turn to Allah make
talba at his repentance and fight with
us the soldiers who fight in the day and
night Allah is most forgiving I am not
long live isil long live Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi Abdullah Abu everit IBN
Gordon Alam Riki just before this yet
another convert to Islam Lionel Williams
was sentenced to in Virginia to 20 years
in prison for attempting to fund the
Islamic State Williams also plotted
Jihad attacks against police officers
and still another con number to Islam
Nicholas young was also recently found
guilty of attempting to Aid the Islamic
State young was a former Metro Transit
police officer in Washington D.C who
while the George Mason University had
been active in both Roxy and the Muslim
Student Association
not long before that in mid-november a
Los Angeles man named John Patrice Hale
was arrested for making a series of
threats to the Los Angeles Sheriff's
Department's court services division
website
our Brotherhood will celebrate today
when Allah sets the explosives planted
in Inglewood Sheriff vehicles at
Inglewood Court Hale wrote and a law
willing we will be able to take out as
many officers that pull out your parking
structure it will be a plus to take part
of your American School across the
street Isis will have Revenge today
and yet another message Hale wrote All
praises to Allah today we will detonate
an explosive at your La Brea and Arbor
Vitae location if your our needs aren't
met by your company Isis
all those converts to Islam were
plotting murder in Mayhem in just two
months span the list of converts to
Islam who've gotten the idea that their
new religion commands them to commit
treason and mass murder is quite long
and growing steadily yet law enforcement
and intelligence officials have hitherto
up to now show no interest whatsoever in
this phenomenon
now if converts to Christianity we're
turning so regularly to violence and
Sedition would they be so blase I'm
Robert Spencer
[Music]